moved into a new place how you guys like
it yeah then I take a [ __ ] mother hey
what is going on YouTube
how's your week everybody you guys look
good yeah said you got a booger hanging
from your nose
do not worry many a times I have been
there to my friends with the little
green monster swinging from my nostrils
is that a father what the trip is he no
bugger we still trying [ __ ] so you know
what's interesting I started browsing
through a lot of my comments and I
guessed on a few videos before in the
past I said that I don't watch a lot of
YouTube so I took your advice I went
online I saw other vloggers who saw what
they were talking about and I found
something very interesting why do so
many youtubers when their viewers ask
them about having a hard time and how to
deal with it they always tell you just
to smile thrilling that when [ __ ]
happens a real life solution is just for
you to keep your chin up and you know
what I've got to tell you guys something
that right there is the dumbest [ __ ]
device I've ever heard in my life so
when [ __ ] constantly happens the only
thing you have to do is go around
singing the Sun will shine under the day
I completely agree about letting all the
petty [ __ ] go and not letting somebody
else's ill intent and bad mood just
affect you for the rest of your day or
even your life but sometimes you got to
let the dragon breathe now fire coburn
because you have to ask yourself
sometimes what if I don't run do smile
buddy buddy but interfere man I feel
like a lot of advice when it comes to
dealing with adversity people tell you
that anger is not an emotion that should
be felt but sometimes it's yes it's okay
to be angry and that is as long as you
don't let your anger control you and
affect your mood for the rest of your
day sometimes though you just got us
yeah for me every now and then I just
had to say the word Shh [ __ ]
who here has heard of the saying that if
you feel angry you've already lost the
battle [ __ ] you know what happens when
I'm angry and then people don't let me
curse it's like holding in a sneeze you
mother
don't do it yeah
do honestly a lot of you guys out there
think that's smiling through everything
and just ignoring your problems is a
real good way to solve your issues and
once again small things yeah smile
through it brush it off your shoulders
but it's not going to work all the time
and when you're holding your anger guess
what it stores up it bottles up and next
thing you know look a big I'm always
happy you know why cuz I let out a [ __ ]
every now and then I don't think that
solution works for everything and I
think it's just a form of pseudo
positivity meaning that a lot of people
just give people answers in a positive
light even though it doesn't solve like
here's this for an example how many
times have you heard somebody say this
[ __ ] t if you are being bullied just
smile because you know that you are
better than there really because I'm
supposed to smile through it because I'm
better than them but they don't know if
they're supposed to know it so they
don't bully me really
somebody is smashing their fist into my
face and I'm supposed to smile and give
them a bigger target to obliterate my
teeth with he's got a punch him you
better shut the hell up floss sock you
in the face well here's my solution are
you trying to die you know what I'll
obviously that type of advice reminds me
of my first year in college when you
would go to your dorm and they would
write all these like positive [ __ ] on
the dorm walls
one of the biggest types of advice that
was floating around that time was this
concept of positive imagery which is
basically saying that if you got
problems you should imagine that hey you
in a car accident imagine you're not
there your wife left you imagine she
dead end you're constipated imagine you
have diarrhea and listen I'm not saying
having positive thoughts is a terrible
thing no you should do that because I do
that in my everyday life I wake up with
positivity but what I am saying is that
when somebody asks you for a solution or
some genuine advice don't give them the
[ __ ] answer of Jeff smiling
sometimes it's okay for you not to smile
and sometimes it's okay for you to be
angry it's an emotion that is supposed
to be felt every now and then it will
seriously make you a better person
watch what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do some
charity now
listen here you but pimple go home hey
go home while you keep on coming out I
told you not to come out until I'm done
[ __ ] how'd you got near mine the Sun
will shine another day yeah